big news david dobrik having a very
tough week
uh for those of you who don't know uh
david dobrik
uh who's a big youtuber he's like the
biggest youtuber
uh david dobrik recently i don't know if
he's the biggest youtuber but he's big
one of the biggest issues
he runs an empire right david dobrik
recently shot up a massage parlor
and killed eight people this is truly
tragic most of the nation he shot
he shot a lot of asian people in a
massage parlor
and in response to that dollar shave
club
has ended their relationship with david
dobrik
which makes sense because shaving
massage parlor so david dobrik he
murdered what six asian people
and now this is this is and it's not
funny because none of this is funny but
look at his eyes right there it's the
eyes of a killer he
went into a massage parlor where was it
atlanta and shot
a bunch of people now this is so strange
because everyone's like he's usually
giving people lamborghinis
or he's usually uh i don't know what he
does but he gives away gifts and he
tells people he loves them but this was
very out of character for him
and in response to this dollar shave
club has dropped him
now he apologized now in fairness david
dobert put out a three-minute video
saying he apologized it was let's talk
and david dobrik's video can we play it
yeah we can play are we allowed to play
it we can play it let's play
david dobrik apologizing for shooting
asian people uh in
the atlanta massage parlor and this is
this is
and and i i respect that he apologized
for this because this is
something that i was shocked uh when i
heard that he did this but not that
shock because it always is the ones that
are always
giddy isn't it always the ones that are
happy
and i don't know that it was a racially
motivated shooting i think it was
because what was it it was something
about sex work uh i think
david had a sex addiction and but why
why kill the people at the massage
parlor i don't understand i was
tempted by them they were maybe
masturbating him masturbating other
gentlemen
and uh he's a christian man he said so
so this is a rage killing where he's
david dober killed get the numbers up
how many
eight people he killed six asians he
killed six asians and then two whites
and people are saying it's maybe
racially motivated but
more the facts are that david dobrik
just shot a bunch of you know sex
workers
because he was angry so now this is and
then and
and listen i don't like advertisers
dropping people
but i understand why dollar shave club
did not want to advertise on david
dobrik's show after he
shot eight people in atlanta this
is david dobrik's response and listen i
commend him for saying he's sorry
it takes a a man to say
you're sorry after you've done this
here is david dobrik apologizing for
shooting eight people is this before he
was arrested or when was this
i don't believe he's been arrested for
this no no no he has a lot of clout
keep going this is david dobrik
apologizing i don't think he needs to be
arrested i think this
is pretty heartfelt hey guys it's david
um
i want to come on here real quick and
address some conversations that have
been going on
on the internet yes um i you know i've
made over
600 videos okay and i've made a bunch of
tick tocks
vines instagram stories tweets the whole
thing yeah um and i'm obsessed with what
i do
i love being able to make and they
shouldn't take away from that
listen the fact that he murdered these
people
i believe separating the art from the
artist
so i don't believe that the fact that he
just shot these people in the face
in atlanta should take away from all the
tick tocks and vines
and youtube videos he's done do you
understand
i'm not unreasonable any hole still a
good movie is my point
continue all that i want to do um
that being said consent is something
that's super super important to me
whether i'm shooting with a friend
or shooting with a stranger i always
make sure that whatever the video i'm
putting out i have
the approval shooting with the gun so
he's basically saying
i think what he's saying is he knows it
wasn't consensual that he shot those
people
and it's very different than some of the
pranks or the content he's done
where people say please shoot me you can
shoot me in the leg
you're david dobrik let's put it out
just put me in the description
but what he's saying now is i those sex
workers in the spa
did not consent to being shot because
this was a prank
i don't know if you
i don't know if you it's our last
episode on youtube don't worry about it
but i don't know if you know that but
this was a prank that he was doing
where he was gonna he went into the spa
and he wanted to shoot eight people
as a as a prank as kind of a goof
and then those people were
going to get up covered in fake blood
and he was going to give them
lamborghinis but
what ended up happening was you could
take his word for tonight there were
actually
real bullets in the gun and he was
standing outside the spa with
lamborghinis
and then nobody showed up and they were
all they were all actually dead
so he was very upset like he walked in
and he was like guys
what is how are we going to give them
lamborghini and somebody because david
you actually killed them all they're
actually dead and he's like
oh oh boy
i gotta make a i want to make a video
about that
about killing of the people so let's
let's let's hear them out let's give him
the time of day
from that person um and i also
acknowledge that
those times where a person can change
their mind and
they decide that they no longer want to
be associated and no longer want to be
in the video
and then i'll take the video down and
there's also been moments
where i've looked back on videos and i
realized that
these don't represent me anymore and
they're hurtful to other people and
i don't i don't want them up because
i've grown
you know as a content creator and as a
person and i don't agree
with some of the videos i've posted um
with
the seth situation i'm sorry because
i was like i said i i would just want to
make videos
where everybody in it you know whether
you're participating or watching
is enjoying and having a good time well
you can't
kill people in the spa
what is he talking about this seth
situation oh
i mean you're a producer can you look
this up the seth situation he's saying
something about seth
let's see here
a man has accused him of something named
seth
a woman featured on youtube star david
dobrik's channel said she was raped by a
vlog squad member in
2018 the night they filmed a video about
group sex
uh that's not good article includes
quotes claiming dobrik asked vlog squad
members
jason ashton purchased alcohol for the
woman as they were under 21 and could
not purchase it for themselves
oh listen i don't get into the youtube
thing because it's not my world and i
don't i don't like to pile on people and
i know that
there's a prank where he has someone
kiss uh
he has someone kiss a yeah it's like a
surprise she thinks she's kissing
someone else and she ends up
kissing another person well no it was a
guy who kissed another guy right right
right
but here's my question why is this
overshadowing the fact that he shot
those people
do you do you understand what i mean
like what's going on
can you explain to me i think people
are it's a it's we're still in the midst
of the me too movement kind of yeah
so i think people might just be more
upset am i am i making a mistake here
david dobre killed the people in atlanta
right
i don't think i don't think so
i wait a minute are you telling me that
let me see can you please google david
dobrik
murdering the people in atlanta and i'll
see that i'm right okay
david dobrik murders asians in atlanta
murders asians murders asians in atlanta
atlanta correct hold on
this is saying someone else did this
hmm is this how strong his pr
team is that they're just now gonna hang
this on another guy
like they found a patsy maybe or
i could have been certain that he did
this
where am i getting that if it's not true
i don't want to spread misinformation
but i'm
almost positive that david dober killed
these people
see atlanta atlanta
massacre david dobrik okay atlanta
google that
atlanta massacre david dobrik did it
did it did it david dober did it atlanta
massacre any any combination of those
words
they're talking about sexual assault
here it's
murder he murdered these people
did he sexually assault the victims or
that's a great question
was this unrelated was david dobrik down
there sexually assaulting people
and then another guy murdered them
i don't know what's going on and i want
someone to explain it to me and i'm
unhappy
i'm not some rube
all right this has gone on long enough
we're gonna get in
probably trouble for that i think david
dobrik's maybe a few weeks from coming
on this program is that
i think i maybe put i i think i'm
overestimating his problems
by saying that is it bad i know dollar
shave club is out
how bad is it is it bad enough where he
could come on here
is it that bad yet he wants to have a
tonight show like jimmy fallon
his hero he wants to do a tonight show
and interview like tana mojo or people
like that about
their day how's your day
and i i i hope he's still able to do
that even though he murdered those
people
i believe in second chances like christ